Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日特惠让您的夏天即刻开启。是时候用Next烤炉、四燃烧器燃气烤炉来开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需199美元。还有汉普顿湾西格罗夫（Hampton Bay West Grove）七件套户外餐桌椅，整个季度陪伴您欢聚，仅售49美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受超低价格保证。售完即止，价格不适用于5月14日或5月27日，仅限美国，有例外情况。详情请查阅HomeDepot.com/pricematch。
Are there songs that take you back in time? Maybe that summer anthem that played endlessly the year you were 16, or the first dance from your wedding, or even an ad jingle from childhood. Whatever it is, hearing even a snippet of the right music can transport us back decades and make us feel the emotions we felt back then. Today we're going to talk about why that happens, and the many ways that music, memory, emotion, and imagination intertwine. So why do some songs make us happy or sad? Why do some give us chills and others make us want to dance? Why do some pieces of music transport us back in time? Is there a reason that people are especially attached to music from their teenage years? How do our culture and our expectations affect the way we experience music?
有没有哪首歌能带你穿越回过去？也许是当你16岁时无休止播放的那首夏日金曲，或是你婚礼上的第一支舞，甚至是一段童年的广告歌。无论是什么，只要听到正确音乐的哪怕一小段，就能把我们带回几十年前，让我们重新感受到当年的情绪。今天我们将探讨为什么会这样，以及音乐、记忆、情感和想象力交织的多种方式。那么，为什么有些歌会让我们快乐或悲伤？为什么有些歌会让我们起鸡皮疙瘩，而另一些则让我们想跳舞？为什么有些音乐作品能带回过去？人们对青少年时期的音乐格外有依恋，这有什么原因吗？我们的文化和期望又是如何影响我们体验音乐的方式的？
And finally, why are we so drawn to some songs that we want to listen to them over and over again? Yet, when other songs get stuck in our heads, we call them earworms and they drive us slightly crazy. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the Flagship Podcast. of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Elizabeth Margulis, who directs the music cognition lab at Princeton University. Her research combines cognitive science, musicology, and music theory to study questions such as how music intersects with memory and imagination, how culture affects the way we experience music, why we like repetition in music, and why some songs become
最后，为什么我们会被某些歌曲深深吸引，以至于想一遍又一遍地听？然而，当其他歌曲在脑海中挥之不去时，我们称之为“洗脑歌”，它们让我们有点抓狂。欢迎收看美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学畅谈》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是伊丽莎白·马古利斯（Elizabeth Margulis）博士，她领导着普林斯顿大学的音乐认知实验室。她的研究结合了认知科学、音乐学和音乐理论，探讨诸如音乐如何与记忆和想象力交织、文化如何影响我们的音乐体验、为什么我们喜欢音乐中的重复，以及为什么有些歌曲会变成
earworms. She's the author of many scientific papers and three books on repeat how music plays the mind, the psychology of music, a very short introduction, and her latest, the science music borderlands, reckoning with the past and imagining the future. Before she became a researcher, Dr. Margulis, trained as a classical pianist. She holds a bachelor's degree in piano performance from the Peabody Conservatory of Music and a PhD from Columbia University. Dr. Maggoulas, thank you for for joining me today. My pleasure. So happy to be here. I talked a moment ago about how the right song can transport us back to a particular time
“洗脑歌”等问题。她是许多科学论文的作者，并著有三本书：《重复：音乐如何拨动心弦》（On Repeat: How Music Plays the Mind）、《音乐心理学：极简入门》（The Psychology of Music: A Very Short Introduction），以及她的最新著作《科学音乐边境：清算过去与想象未来》（The Science Music Borderlands: Reckoning with the Past and Imagining the Future）。在成为研究人员之前，马古利斯博士曾接受过古典钢琴训练。她拥有皮博迪音乐学院钢琴演奏学士学位和哥伦比亚大学博士学位。马古利斯博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。我的荣幸。很高兴能来到这里。我刚才提到，一首合适的歌可以把我们带回特定的时间
or a moment in our life. Why is that? Why has music so strongly connected to memory? People have been fascinated by this question for ages. And in fact, it's not only music that people suspect to have this power. So think of the famous Medellin in Proust, where you take a bite or smell something from your childhood. Suddenly all kinds of vivid details come back to you. So because there are sort of other sensory stimuli that can have a similar effect, one of the first questions people have asked
或我们生活中的某个时刻。这是为什么呢？为什么音乐与记忆联系得如此紧密？人们对这个问题着迷已久。事实上，人们怀疑拥有这种力量的不仅仅是音乐。想想普鲁斯特小说里著名的玛德琳蛋糕，当你咬上一口或闻到童年时期的某种气味时，突然各种生动的细节就会涌上心头。因此，由于还有其他感官刺激可以产生类似的效果，人们提出的首要问题之一就是
is, is there really anything special about music when it comes to autobiographical memory? And one of my favorite studies on that topic was conducted by Amy Belfy. and what she did was compare the autobiographical memories that were prompted by hit songs from specific years versus famous faces that it had a lot of airtime in those same specific years. The idea is they're both kind of similarly repeated and kind of in circulation at a particular time. So she just show people the face or play people a bit of the song and ask them whether it triggered some memory from their life.
在自传体记忆方面，音乐真的有什么特别之处吗？关于这个话题，我最喜欢的研究之一是由艾米·贝尔菲（Amy Belfy）进行的。她所做的是比较由特定年份的热门歌曲引发的自传体记忆，与在这些特定年份拥有大量播放时间的著名面孔所引发的记忆。这个想法是，这两者在特定时期都受到类似的重复并在某种程度上流通。因此，她只是向人们展示面孔或播放一段歌曲，并询问它们是否触发了他们生活中的某些记忆。
if so, to describe it. She found indeed that the music produced especially vivid kind of memories. So people had more kind of descriptive language, more sensory detail. It was really coming back in a more lifelike way than it was for simply the prompt of a visual image and a face. So it really seems to be a real phenomenon. So why do so many people get especially attached to music from their teen or young adult years? I mean, most of us aren't wearing the same clothes. reading the same books that we did back then, but we're still listening to the same music. Why do we do this? Yeah, for better, for worse, indeed.
如果是，请描述一下。她确实发现，音乐会产生特别生动的记忆。因此，人们拥有更多的描述性语言、更多的感官细节。与仅仅通过视觉图像和面孔提示相比，它确实以一种更逼真的方式回归。所以这似乎是一个真实的现象。那么，为什么这么多人对青少年或青年时期的音乐有着特殊的依恋呢？我的意思是，我们大多数人现在不会穿那时的衣服，也不会读那时的书，但我们仍然在听那时的音乐。我们为什么要这样做？是的，不管好坏，确实如此。
I think there's an interesting clue we get about that from looking at the other eras of our life that function similarly. So we do have a reminiscence bump for the music of our adolescence. That means, number one, we tend to recognize more of it, continue to like it more. I think this is amply evidenced in the Super Bowl this year where I think a lot of millennials got excited about the usher songs and a lot of current teenagers were kind of confused. And then people have more autobiographical memories for music from their adolescence. But there's also a little smaller, a secondary remittance bump for music from people's parents' adolescence. And the thinking there is that when you're a tiny person and you don't have agency over the radio,
我认为，通过观察我们生活中以类似方式运作的其他时期，我们可以得到一个有趣的线索。对于我们青春期的音乐，我们确实有“记忆高峰”（reminiscence bump）。这意味着，第一，我们往往能认出更多这样的音乐，并且继续更喜欢它。我认为今年的超级碗充分证明了这一点，我想很多千禧一代对亚瑟小子（Usher）的歌曲感到兴奋，而许多现在的青少年则有点困惑。然后，人们对青春期音乐有更多的自传体记忆。但还有一个较小的、次要的记忆高峰，针对的是人们父母青春期的音乐。那里的想法是，当你还是个小不点、对收音机没有控制权时，
your parents are in control of what you're hearing while they're making you dinner or, you know, going about cleaning up your messes or what have you. So you get this kind of early repeated exposure to the music that they are stuck with from the time that they were teenagers. So it kind of propagates generationally. So there really is a lot of evidence that it has to do with exposure. And people think a lot about the idea that during your adolescence, you're really invested in developing your identity and making links with other people around shared aspects of your identity.
你的父母在给你做饭，或者清理你弄的一团糟等等的时候，他们掌控着你正在听什么。因此，你会对他们十几岁时不得不听的音乐产生这种早期、重复的接触。所以它会代代相传。因此，确实有很多证据表明这与接触有关。人们经常思考这样一个想法：在你的青春期，你非常投入于发展你的身份认同，并围绕你身份认同的共同方面与其他人建立联系。
And music kind of plays this important function in solidifying those connections and those social roles. So it's almost that there's a connection to brain development. Yeah, exactly. There are ideas about that. And I mean, part of the reason that this really matters is because there are really interesting clinical ramifications to, I mean, it's kind of fun and interesting that the music of our adolescent sticks with us.
而音乐在巩固这些联系和社会角色方面发挥着重要的这种重要功能。所以这几乎就像是与大脑发育有关。是的，完全是这样。有一些关于这方面的观点。我的意思是，这真的很重要的一部分原因在于，它有着非常有趣的临床影响，我的意思是，我们青春期的音乐能留在我们心中，这既有趣又好玩。
But this can be really important for people experiencing dementia, for example, where if you really calibrate the right music and, expose them to something that was really meaningful to them at that time of their life, there's lots of evidence that this can trigger memory improvements and interesting clinical potential as well. Let's talk for a minute about the connection between music and emotion. What makes a song sad or happy? Does happy music have to be in a major key while sad music is in a minor key? What role do lyrics play? And what about tempo? First, on the lyrics topic, I'd say people really vary.
但这对经历痴呆症等情况的人来说非常重要，例如，如果你真正校准了合适的音乐，并让他们接触到在那个人生阶段对他们真正有意义的东西，有大量证据表明这可以触发记忆的改善，同时也具有有趣的临床潜力。让我们花一分钟时间来讨论音乐和情感之间的联系。是什么让一首歌曲变得悲伤或快乐？快乐的音乐一定要用大调，而悲伤的音乐一定要用小调吗？歌词起到了什么作用？节奏呢？首先，关于歌词这个话题，我想说每个人真的各不相同。
It sort of seems to be a trait-level characteristic that people reliably are different on. Some people really pay attention to lyrics and remember all the details of what a singer is saying in a particular song. And others of them, like myself, have heard a song maybe, you know, 300 times. Could sing the whole thing, but I have no idea what the actual words are. I just don't pay attention. And there's a certain number of people who are really one way or the other. And you tend to not move back and forth that much between this. Yeah.
这似乎是一个特质层面的特征，人们在这个方面有着可靠的差异。有些人真的很关注歌词，并记得歌手在特定歌曲中所说的话的所有细节。而另一些人，比如我自己，可能听过一首歌，比方说，300遍。可以把整首歌唱出来，但我根本不知道真正的词是什么。我就是不关注。有一定数量的人真的是倾向于某一种。而且你往往不会在这两者之间来回变动太多。是的。
And then so the emotion piece is pretty interesting because people do use music frequently for mood regulation. Right? Like you're really depressed. And so you turn on some particular song or some particular album. And what's interesting there is sometimes the music that makes you feel better paradoxically is sad music. So I'm sad. I go put on an album of songs that also feel really sad.
然后，情感这部分非常有趣，因为人们确实经常使用音乐来调节情绪。对吧？比如你真的很沮丧。于是你打开某首特定的歌或某张特定的专辑。这里有趣的是，有时能让你感觉更好的音乐，矛盾的是，正是悲伤的音乐。所以我很悲伤。我去播放一张同样感觉非常悲伤的歌曲专辑。
And maybe I have some sense that my sadness is seen or validated or shared, sort of like a surrogate social experience there with music. And so what this means is that sometimes I can get happier through music that's expressive of sadness. So one thing research is really careful about is distinguishing what emotion the music is expressing seems to be expressing versus how that makes you feel. So sometimes sad music can make you feel happy. But again, about key, I mean, it doesn't have to be a minor key to make, to be sad. You can have music in a major key and it could still trigger sadness. Absolutely. Yes. That's right. Yes. And in fact,
也许我有一种感觉，我的悲伤被看到了、被验证了或是被分享了，这有点像音乐中的一种替代性社会体验。这意味着有时我可以通过表达悲伤的音乐变得更加快乐。因此，研究非常谨慎的一点是，区分音乐所表达的情感（似乎正在表达的情感）与这带给你的感受。所以有时悲伤的音乐可以让你感到快乐。但话说回来，关于调性，我的意思是，它不一定非要是小调才能让人悲伤。你可以有一首大调的音乐，它依然能引发悲伤。完全可以。是的。就是这样。事实上，
really think, you know, if we really understood the formula to create a song with a particular emotion, I mean, we'd be living in a different world than we live there, right? Right. And the idea is there's all this interesting stylistic change happening all the time. We develop, so there are certain kind of standard things that tend to happen in the songs you listen to. And then those standard things become overused. And people kind of get sick of them. And then the style changes. That's how you get it to be that you can put a song in the radio and say, oh, I don't know that song, but it sounds like it's from like the 2010s,
真的认为，如果我们真的懂得了创作一首带有特定情感的歌曲的公式，我的意思是，我们所生活的世界就会与现在不同了，对吧？对的。这里的想法是，所有这些有趣的风格变化一直在发生。我们发展出了，所以有一些特定的标准事物往往会发生在你听的歌里。然后那些标准的事物变得被过度使用。人们有点对它们感到厌烦。然后风格就变了。这就是为什么你可以把一首歌放在广播里并说：“哦，我不知道那首歌，但听起来像是2010年代的”，
or that sounds like it's from the 1980s, right? Because there are these certain features that kind of come through and then fade out. And part of that has to do with things that were surprising and interesting kind of become standardized. So it's a dynamic kind of process. There's no constant, eternal way to have produced a certain effect in music. It's a really dynamic kind of interaction between what's happening in the style of the music you're listening to a lot, how you respond to it, how that changes. This is really kind of a more exciting richer process.
或者“听起来像是1980年代的”，对吧？因为有这些某些特征会显现出来然后又逐渐淡出。这部分与那些曾经令人惊讶和有趣的事情变得标准化有关。所以这是一个动态的过程。在音乐中，没有一种恒定的、永恒的方式来产生某种特定的效果。这是你经常听的音乐风格中正在发生的事情、你如何反应、这又是如何变化的，三者之间真正动态的一种互动。这其实是一种更令人兴奋、更丰富的过程。
Let me ask an aesthetic question. Are there pieces of music that are considered universally beautiful? For instance, I don't think I've ever met anybody who hates Pockelbell's canon. And I think a lot of people think that Leonard Cohen's Hallelujah is a wonderful song. Are there others and what constitutes music that is considered universally beautiful if there is such a thing? I love that you brought up Pockabell's candidate D because in fact I have a great counter example to your claim, which is this one cellist slash comedians. you can find this on YouTube, has an entire routine called the pocket belt rant where he complains about not only having to play pocketbells, canon and D, all these kind of processionals, but then super complains about the fact that the same progression that underlies that piece can be found in 8 million other songs as well. So he's just like fed up, makes him, makes him crazy. So yeah, the idea about universal. in music is there's music feels so powerful to us. We have so little sense of how it works
让我问一个美学问题。有没有被认为具有普遍美感的音乐作品？例如，我想我从来没遇到过讨厌帕赫贝尔《D大调卡农》（Pachelbel's Canon）的人。而且我认为很多人认为莱昂纳德·科恩（Leonard Cohen）的《哈利路亚》（Hallelujah）是一首美妙的歌曲。还有其他的吗？如果存在这样一种东西的话，构成被普遍认为美丽的音乐的要素是什么？我很高兴你提到了帕赫贝尔的《D大调卡农》，事实上我有一个很好的反例可以反驳你的观点，那就是有一位大提琴家兼喜剧演员，
intuitively, feels kind of magic, that it's tempting to think, you know, whatever profound experience I'm having to this song must be universally shared. Like it's hard to put yourself in another set of ears and imagine the way something might, uh, sound different. But in fact, lots of research shows that even very basic. basic things about how a particular chord sounds or how a particular collection of pitches sounds really varies according to the kind of exposure that you've had within your life and the musical systems that you've been kind of trained up on in terms of your ear. So we're really finding that this prescription for universality is really not there in exactly the way that our intuition
你可以在YouTube上找到这个，他有一整段名为“卡农咆哮”（Pachelbel rant）的常规表演，在表演中他不仅抱怨不得不演奏帕赫贝尔的《D大调卡农》以及所有这些婚礼进行曲，而且还极其强烈地抱怨支撑那首作品的相同进行曲也能在其他800万首歌曲中找到。所以他简直受够了，这让他有点抓狂。所以，是的，关于音乐中的普遍性的想法是，音乐对我们来说感觉太强大了。我们对它是如何运作的知之甚少，
which sometimes suggest. On the other side of the same coin, what about music that's considered universally ugly or unpleasant? I'm thinking about, like, during the Renaissance, right, the Catholic Church forbade the use of the augmented fourth, which they called Diabolous Musica. What was it about this particular chord that got people so riled up?
凭直觉感觉它有点像魔法，这很容易让人产生这样的想法：你知道，我对这首歌所经历的任何深刻体验一定是在全人类中共享的。就像很难设身处地去想象某种东西可能会发出不同声音的方式一样。但事实上，大量的研究表明，即使是非常基础的、关于特定和弦听起来如何或特定音高集合听起来如何的基础事物，也会根据你在生活中所经历的接触以及你在耳朵训练方面所接受的音乐体系而产生真正的差异。所以我们真的发现，这种关于普遍性的处方并不完全存在于我们的直觉中有时会暗示的那种方式中。
And is there music that's universally considered ugly for want of a better descriptor? Right. So people think a lot about dissidents, about notes that you play them together and they kind of sound grating or they don't sound sweet and sonorous together. And there's a big history of psychoacoustic explanations. Like think about Pythagoras, this idea that there's something about the physical property of resonating bodies that there's a long history of people thinking, oh, there's these small, special kind of numeric relationships between pitches that sound good together, and that's why they sound good. And this is like, must be kind of a baked in feature. Whereas we now know, for example, with work by Josh McDermott and Nora Jacoby, Melinda McPherson, they worked with people in rural Bolivia called the Chimane, who don't have a lot of music that is, um,
硬币的另一面，被认为普遍丑陋或令人不快的音乐又如何呢？我想到了，比如在文艺复兴时期，天主教堂禁止使用增四度，他们称之为“音乐中的魔鬼”（Diabolus in Musica）。这个特定的和弦究竟有什么让人如此抓狂的地方？
has multiple voices going on at once. So usually it's kind of one melody at a time. And they basically made a bunch of songs for them, taking these melodies and adding another line so that you had either a very sweet-sounding, consonant kind of series of sounds, or a quite-grading, dissonant series of sounds. That was like, you know,
有没有哪种音乐被退而求其次地普遍认为是不美的？是的。所以人们对不和谐音思考得很多，关于你把它们一起演奏听起来有点刺耳或者它们听起来并不甜美和谐的音符。并且有着悠久的心理声学解释历史。就像想想毕达哥拉斯，这种观点认为，共鸣体的物理属性有某种东西，人们长期以来一直认为，哦，听起来不错的音高之间存在着这些微小的、特殊的数字关系，这就是它们听起来不错的原因。这就像一定是一个内置的特征。而我们现在知道，例如通过乔什·麦克德莫特（Josh McDermott）、诺拉·雅各比（Nora Jacoby）和梅林达·麦克弗森（Melinda McPherson）的工作，他们与玻利维亚农村地区被称为奇曼（Chimane）的人合作，他们并没有很多音乐，呃，
either a dissonant accompaniment to this melody that was quite familiar to them or a consonant accompaniment. And the chimale had no trouble whatsoever noting that these were different kinds of accompaniments. Like you could categorize those ones, you know, kind of go together. These ones that sound sweet. These ones that sound grading kind of go together. But there was absolutely no difference for them in terms of which they liked or found pleasurable.
同时有多个声部进行。所以通常它是一次一个旋律。他们基本上为他们创作了一系列歌曲，采用这些旋律并添加了另一行，这样你就会听到非常甜美、协和的声音系列，或者相当刺耳、不和谐的声音系列。那就像是，你知道，
Like truly, they tested so many different ways. There was just nothing about a consonant accompaniment that they liked. or enjoyed any more than a dissonant, a compliment. Yeah, and I mean, I have a range of friends with such varied musical taste, including people who swear that they can't get their children to sleep without playing, you know, death metal. Like, you know, there's just, it's to each their own, yeah. What about exposure to music across cultures?
要么是对他们相当熟悉的这个旋律的不和谐伴奏，要么是协和伴奏。奇曼人毫无困难地注意到这些是不同种类的伴奏。就像你可以把那些分类，你知道，（觉得）它们是一起走的。这些听起来很甜美的。这些听起来刺耳的有点归为一类。但对他们来说，在他们喜欢或觉得悦耳的程度方面，绝对没有任何区别。
I mean, like, it's almost like food, you know, in some cultures you would, eat a kind of food which in America we wouldn't like. And there's music that comes from the east that may sound dissonant to our ears, where our music may sound dissonant to eastern ears. I mean, how does this come about? Is it a matter of what we're exposed to in our youth, what becomes acceptable and consonant to us? Yeah, it's very similar to what happens in language acquisition. So if you look at little tiny babies and what they're able to detect, in terms of phonemes, in terms of like the basic units of language, there's a lot they can do before they specialize and prune their abilities and become little experts in their own language.
真的，他们测试了许多不同的方法。对于协和的伴奏，他们并没有表现出比不和谐伴奏更多一点的喜爱或享受。是的，我的意思是，我有一群音乐品味迥异的朋友，包括一些发誓说如果不给他们的孩子播放（你知道）死亡金属音乐，就无法让孩子入睡的人。就像，你知道，萝卜青菜，各有所爱，是的。跨文化接触音乐的情况又如何呢？
So an example would be distinguishing between the sounds of R and L, but in some other languages, those sounds are kind of together in one category. And so depending on the kind of exposure a baby has, they'll either kind of develop this ability to separate different kinds of continuous changes on the spectrum from R to L into two different binary categories or not. And you really see this ability develop. Or, I mean, another way of thinking about that is they lose the ability to make that distinction if that distinction is not relevant in their language. And we see the same thing with music.
举个例子，比如区分R和L的发音，但在其他一些语言中，这些发音在某种程度上属于同一个类别。因此，根据婴儿所处的接触环境，他们要么会培养出这种能力，将R到L的光谱中各种连续的变化分离开来，分成两个不同的二元类别，或者不会。你真的能看到这种能力的发展。或者说，换一种方式来思考，如果这种区别在他们的语言中不重要，他们就会失去做出这种区别的能力。我们在音乐中也看到了同样的情况。
So there have been great studies with babies. using special kinds of musical meters. So most of the songs that we hear on the radio, let's say, in the States, are going to be like in two or in three. Groups of, you know, beats are in groups of two or three, these kind of simple meters. So they're evenly divided. Whereas in other styles, so Balkan folk music, for example, it's very common to have meters that are in five or seven. You have uneven groups. You have like three followed by two, and then three and then two.
因此，针对婴儿进行过很棒的研究，使用了特殊种类的音乐节拍。所以我们在电台上听到的绝大多数歌曲，比方说在美国的歌曲，通常是两拍或三拍的。也就是拍子的组合是两拍或三拍，这种简单的节拍。所以它们是均等划分的。然而在其他风格中，比如巴尔干民间音乐，拥有五拍或七拍的节拍非常常见。你们有不均匀的组合。比如先是三个接着两个，然后是三个接着两个。
And that's very unfamiliar for other kinds of musical styles. So babies, it turns out, start out, you know, it's no problem for them. They don't care if it's like a group of five or a group of two or a group of seven. They're like equally good at all of them. But then you keep raising them in the U.S. or Canada or something and they lose that ability. by like 12 months old, they don't know what's going on with the five, you know, the groups, music just in groups of five or seven. But what's cool is you can resurrect that ability really easily. So researchers just gave them the parents, CDs of some Balkan folk music, sent them home and said, you know, over the course of a week, just occasionally play this CD.
而这对于其他种类的音乐风格来说非常陌生。所以事实证明，婴儿一开始，你知道的，这对他们来说完全不是问题。他们才不在乎这到底是五个一组、两个一组还是七个一组。他们对所有这些都同样在行。但接着如果你继续在美国或加拿大等地抚养他们，他们就会失去这种能力。到大约12个月大时，他们就搞不懂这五拍是怎么回事了，也就是那些五拍或七拍的音乐组合。但酷炫的是，你可以非常轻松地恢复这种能力。所以研究人员只是把一些巴尔干民间音乐的CD给家长们，让他们带回家，并说，你知道的，在一周的时间里，偶尔放一下这张CD。
They did that. And then the babies came back and suddenly they're perfectly, this ability's back, like no problem. So just passive exposure to certain kinds of sonic patterns is enough to support the development of that ability at that age. It's not so easy if you try to do the same thing in an adult. It takes a lot more exposure and a lot more kind of like explicit training to regain an ability that you lost when you were kids.
他们照做了。然后婴儿们回来了，突然间他们完美地恢复了，这种能力又回来了，就像完全没有问题一样。因此，仅仅是被动接触某些类型的声波模式，就足以在那个年龄支持该能力的发展。如果你试图在一个成年人身上做同样的事情，就没那么容易了。这需要多得多的接触，以及更多明确的训练，才能重新获得你在童年时失去的能力。
So there's lots of parallels there to what it's like to try to learn a language when you're older versus when you're a kid. Really similar kinds of sets of processes. It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plants started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay.
所以这与你年纪较大时试图学语言和年纪小时学语言的情况有很多相似之处。这是一组非常相似的过程。现在正值盛花期，我的业务规模正在迅速扩大。为了让花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择Google Fi无线网络的原因。即使在蜂巢蜂鸣般繁忙的时候，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，不限量套餐每月只需35美元起。这可真是一个不会错过的优惠。
explore GoogleFi wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. So there are areas in the brain for speech and smell and hearing. Is there a music area in our brain? That's a question that animated a lot of research for a lot of time. And the answer really seems to be no. In fact, it seems to be that what's so amazing and special about music,
今天就来探索Google Fi无线网络套餐吧。需另付税费和政府规费。Google Fi无线网络在网络高流量期间不受数据流量降速影响。因此，大脑中存在负责语言、嗅觉和听觉的区域。我们的大脑中存在音乐区吗？这是一个在很长一段时间内激发了大量研究的问题。而答案似乎确实是否定的。事实上，关于音乐，最神奇、最特别的地方似乎在于，
is that it draws on so many other different abilities and so many other different parts of your brain. So if you think about what's needed to just perform or even listen to and make sense of and be moved by music, there's these motor aspects, motor control regions about, in fact, even if you passively listen to music, it turns out, you rely on motor areas of your brain to process music that has a beat. There's this very tight connection between the auditory and the motor system. You need to have cognitive faculty, right, to be able to process and evaluate the sounds and make sense of how they relate to one another. To make sense of what the song might be about, you have to have some kind of empathetic or emotional kind of sense. It just starts combining so many different things, which is one reason that people look to musical training as,
它调动了如此之多的其他不同能力，以及你大脑中如此之多的其他不同部分。因此，如果你思考一下仅仅去表演、甚至只是听音乐、理解音乐并被音乐感动所需要的东西，这里有运动层面，比如运动控制区域，事实上，甚至当你被动听音乐时，你会发现，你依靠大脑的运动区域来处理带有节拍的音乐。听觉系统和运动系统之间存在着非常紧密的联系。你需要具备认知能力，对吧，能够处理和评估声音，并理解它们之间是如何相互关联的。为了理解这首歌可能在讲什么，你必须具备某种同理心或情感感知。它开始结合如此之多的不同事物，这也是人们将音乐训练视为...
a resource for scaffolding and all kinds of other abilities across the course of development. So if there's no musical center in the brain, how do we understand what happens to people say who were never musical in their lives, have a head injury, and can suddenly play Beethoven? Right. There are all kinds of oddities of that sort. One is tone deafness, where, in fact, This is kind of an interesting phenomenon because, you know, as I'm talking now, I bet a certain percentage of people listening are like, that is me. I am definitely tone deaf. But in fact, lots of people who think they're tone deaf are really not.
在整个发展过程中，为各种其他能力提供脚手架和支撑的资源。所以，如果大脑中没有音乐中心，我们该如何理解那些一生中从未接触过音乐的人，却在头部受伤后突然能够弹奏贝多芬呢？对吧。这种奇奇怪怪的现象各种各样。其中之一就是失音症，事实上，这是一个相当有趣的现象，因为，正如我现在所说的那样，我敢打赌一定比例的听众会觉得：那正是我。我绝对是五音不全。但事实上，许多自认为五音不全的人其实并不是。
Because if someone's truly tone deaf, the standard is that the test for assessing that involves listening to a melody and then you listen to the same melody and one note. is like super off. And people who are tone deaf cannot hear, they don't know if the melodies were the same or not. But it's completely obvious to anyone who is not toned deaf that those are not the same. Often, you know, someone who claims they're toned off,
因为如果一个人真的五音不全，用于评估的标准涉及听一段旋律，然后你听同一旋律但其中有一个音符超级离谱。而五音不全的人听不出来，他们不知道旋律是否相同。但对于任何不是五音不全的人来说，这完全是显而易见的，那些并不相同。通常情况下，你知道的，某个自称五音不全的人，
it's totally apparent to them that something dramatic has changed. What makes them think they're toned of is that they have troubles singing, which can be a production problem, like a problem with controlling your voice to matter, kind of what you hear versus a perception problem, which is what tone deafness is. And this kind of goes for the whole kind of range of special skills and special deficits related to music is that it has to do with little subparts and components in ways things
他们能完全明显地感觉到发生了某种戏剧性的变化。让他们觉得自己五音不全的原因是他们在唱歌时遇到困难，这可能是个输出问题，比如控制你的声音来配合你所听到内容的控制问题，而不是感知问题，这才是失音症的本质。这种情况适用于与音乐相关的各种特殊技能和特殊缺陷的整个范围，这与事物如何连接的小子部分和组件有关，
are connected, right? So you can get these interesting disassociations where, for example, somebody loses the ability to produce speech, like they have aphasia. But they've preserved the ability to sing, for example. And that seems mysterious. Like, why could someone not be able to say the sentence, I lost my book, but can sing Mary had a little lamb, you know, with no problem whatsoever? So there's a whole kind of way of treating aphasia or addressing it that relies on the preserved ability to sing where people gradually kind of scaffolding.
对吧？所以你会看到这些有趣的解离现象，例如，某人失去了产生语言的能力，比如他们患有失语症。但他们保留了唱歌的能力，例如。这看起来很神秘。为什么一个人不能说“我丢了我的书”这句话，却可以毫无问题地唱出“玛丽有只小羊羔”呢？所以有一整套治疗或应对失语症的方法，依赖于保留下来的唱歌能力，人们在他们仍然能够产生的歌曲基础之上，逐渐构建起...
in more speech-like kind of utterances on top of the song that they're still able to produce. Yeah, so I guess what I'm saying in response to your initial question is that there's a whole, you know, complex interconnected world. So you can just snip out or kind of damage any kind of one part of it. And there's like compensatory things that arise in another area or, you know, some specific. symptom that appears, but it's not kind of characterizing your performance overall, but it is maybe just affecting one bit of how you perform musically. The thing about, like you mentioned, which is people, these tales of people who have had
更多类似语言的表达。是的，所以我想我对你最初问题的回答是，这是一个复杂的、相互关联的世界。因此，你可以剪掉或损害其中的任何一部分。而在另一个领域会出现补偿性的机制，或者会出现某种特定的症状，但这并没有刻画你的整体表现，而可能只是影响了你音乐表现的一小部分。关于你提到的那件事，也就是那些经历过...
a stroke or something and then become incredibly interested in music and just produce a ton of music, I think there's a really interesting kind of thing there that has to do with motivation and interest, which is increased. increasingly acknowledged as a key part of musicality. Let me give you a couple of examples here. So one of the things that people in my field have been trying to do is figure out a way of measuring individual differences in how musical any person is. Right? Because some people, you know, they're just like curating their CDs all day.
中风或其他变故然后变得对音乐极其感兴趣并创作大量音乐的人，我认为其中有一个非常有趣的方面与动机和兴趣有关，这越来越被公认为是音乐性的关键部分。我在这里给你举几个例子。所以，我所在领域的人一直在尝试的事情之一，就是找出一种方法来衡量任何一个人在音乐性上的个体差异。对吧？因为有些人，你知道的，他们一整天都在整理他们的CD，
I guess they're not their playlist. They're curating their playlist all day. You know, they're like going to concerts all the time. They're like weeping when they hear things. is really moving to them. So it's not enough to find out if they play an instrument or if, you know, you have to really start asking questions about musical interests and responsiveness and sensitivity to music.
我想他们不是在整理播放列表。他们一整天都在整理他们的播放列表。你知道的，他们总是去听音乐会。当他们听到某些让他们真正感动的东西时，他们会流泪。所以，仅仅去了解他们是否演奏乐器，或者你是否真的必须开始询问有关音乐兴趣、对音乐的反应能力和敏感性的问题，这还不够。
And so as people have developed those instruments to really be able to measure how musical people start out, this piece about how much interest they have in music and how much motivation they have has seemed more and more important. And in fact, a substrant of research in my field currently has to do with genetic approaches, so trying to look at what might be the genetic underpinnings of these individual differences in musicality. And one of the things that's coming up there that's interesting is that it doesn't seem so much that musical ability itself in terms of performing on an instrument is directly genetically encoded. rather motivation for practicing and interest in and desire to really focus and do this thing a bunch seems to have more of a clear genetic kind of prompt than musical ability itself directly.
因此，随着人们开发出这些能够真正衡量人们音乐天赋起点的工具，他们对音乐有多少兴趣以及有多少动机这一部分显得越来越重要。事实上，我目前的研究领域中的一个研究支流与遗传学方法有关，也就是试图寻找音乐性个体差异背后的基因基础。其中一个很有趣的发现是，就演奏乐器的能力而言，音乐能力本身似乎并不是直接由基因编码的。相反，练习的动机以及真正集中精力并大量做这件事的兴趣和愿望，似乎比音乐能力本身具有更明确的基因驱动。
So I think that's something you're seeing there is that there's just this incredible interest, right, that can happen under certain circumstances and kind of understanding that. that, you know, where it comes from and how to cultivate it and people who maybe don't start out having that passion is very much an open set of research questions, I think is super interesting. Can musical ability be cultivated in almost anyone? I mean, you're talking about how, you know, practice makes you perfect in a sense. But, you know, can people who really don't have that inclination, can they become more musical with time and for over the past few years, an increasing number of longitudinal studies where they've really
所以我想你在那里看到的是，在特定情况下会产生这种不可思议的兴趣，对吧，去理解这一点，你知道的，它来自哪里以及如何培养它，对于那些一开始可能没有那种热情的人来说，这在很大程度上是一组悬而未决的研究问题，我认为这超级有趣。音乐能力几乎可以在任何人身上得到培养吗？我的意思是，你在谈论练习在某种意义上如何能让你变得完美。但是，你知道的，那些真的没有这种倾向的人，随着时间的推移，在过去几年里，越来越多的纵向研究显示，他们真的...
looked at cohorts of kids who are randomly assigned to music lessons and music ensemble experience compared to random assignment to some other kind of set of interventions and looking at how that goes year in and year out. A person who's doing really interesting work there is Sal Habibi at USC. Yeah, and they're really finding that there's a host of benefits that can accrue for people across those kinds of experiences, where, you know, you might not care so much about, like, do they become the most proficient clarinet player in the world? But you really might care about how much they like coming to school, how much they have, you know, a sense of self-worth and connectedness to their kids around them.
观察了一组被随机分配到音乐课和音乐合奏经验的孩子，并将其与随机分配到其他一组干预措施的孩子进行比较，看他们年复一年进展如何。在那项研究中做着非常有趣工作的人是南加州大学的萨尔·哈比比。是的，他们确实发现，对于经历过这些体验的人来说，会带来大量的好处，在这里，你知道的，你可能不那么关心，比如，他们是否成为了世界上最精湛的单簧管演奏家？但你可能真的很关心他们有多喜欢来学校，他们有多少自尊感，以及与周围孩子的连结感。
Like how much are they meeting, state, you know, levels and reading and math? I mean, so I'm not trying to say that musical training is only there to serve these other ends. There's like an important component in and of itself. But lots of these measures are being studied because they're kind of important as far as making the case for funding and involvement of music in schools. Well, let's talk about repetition in music. Your first book was called On Repeat, How Music Plays the Mind. What role does repetition play? And what got you interested in studying this particular aspect?
比如他们达到了多少州级别的阅读和数学水平？我的意思是，我并不是想说音乐培训仅仅是为了服务于这些其他目的。它本身就有一个重要的组成部分。但许多这些指标正在被研究，因为它们在为争取学校音乐教育的资金投入和参与提供理由方面非常重要。好吧，让我们来谈谈音乐中的重复。你的第一本书叫作《论重复：音乐如何拨动心弦》。重复扮演了什么角色？是什么让你对研究这个特定方面感兴趣？
As I was kind of starting out in this field, the models that were really dominant all had to do with language. It was like, here's something about how we know that speech works. Let's take that framework and use it to think about how music works. But there was one part of music that just couldn't fit into that paradigm. done. And that was how kind of ludicrously repetitive music is. Because there's just almost no circumstance in conversation or, you know, other kinds of ordinary language uses where you would repeat yourself to the degree that music ordinarily does. And, you know, we seem to like it, right? The chorus comes back several times in the song, but like, that's not enough. We also have to
当我刚开始涉足这个领域时，占据主导地位的模型都与语言有关。就像是，这是关于我们如何知道语言如何运作的一些内容。让我们采用那个框架来思考音乐是如何运作的。但音乐中有一个部分根本无法契合那个范式。那就是音乐是多么荒谬地重复。因为在对话或你知道的其他日常语言使用中，几乎没有任何情况下你会像音乐通常那样进行重复。而且，你知道的，我们似乎很喜欢它，对吧？副歌在一首歌里多次出现，但是，这还不够。我们还必须...
just then, like, listen to the whole song again and again. In fact, to a degree, agree that sometimes I think people fail to kind of acknowledge themselves. And like, when their Spotify wrapped appears at the end of the year and they see they listen to, you know, Radiohead's specific song, like it get 800 or 20 times or something. It's a little bit sobering. But it really seems like that's an important part of how music works for us. We string together these chains of what happens. We are able to sing it through in our head. We have this sense of participating along with it that seems to be important. And so I really wanted to look at repetition and figure out, you know, what it was doing and
然后，比如，一遍又一遍地听整首歌。事实上，有时候我觉得人们甚至没有意识到这一点。就像当他们在年底看到他们的Spotify年度总结时，他们看到自己听了，你知道的，雷欧赫德的某首特定歌曲，比如听了800多次或类似的数据。这有点让人清醒。但这确实看起来是我们音乐运作方式的重要组成部分。我们将发生的事情串联在一起。我们能够在脑海中把它唱出来。我们有一种与之共同参与的感觉，这似乎很重要。所以我真的想研究重复并弄清楚，你知道的，它在做什么以及...
what it was giving us and not try to kind of pretend that it wasn't existing, which is, I think people were kind of like stressed out or embarrassed. And you think with that repetitive and we're like trying and maybe not make a big deal out of it. But sometimes songs that we don't want to think about get stuck in our heads, right? those dreaded earworms. Why does this happen? And are there some songs that are especially likely to become earworms?
它给我们带来了什么，而不是试图假装它不存在，我认为人们当时有点感到压力或尴尬。而你觉得那样的重复，我们试图可能不去大惊小怪。但有时我们不想去想的歌曲会卡在我们的脑海里，对吧？那些可怕的“洗脑神曲”。为什么会发生这种情况？有没有某些歌曲特别容易变成洗脑神曲？
And then how do we get rid of them? There is some evidence that we're kind of indulging in a sort of mental replay often in order to kind of better encode a series of events that we've experienced. And that, you know, there's just certain circumstances where they kind of like pop up into consciousness. So this is kind of a terrifying thought that you might, there might be lots of you worms percolating in your mental landscape. There's only some of them that kind of pop up into consciousness and that you actually recognize. But yes, there are definitely certain songs that tend to be particularly catchy. And I mean, it's not the same for everyone necessarily. Like people,
然后我们如何摆脱它们呢？有一些证据表明，我们常常沉迷于某种心理重播，以便更好地编码我们经历过的一系列事件。而且，你知道的，在某些特定情况下，它们会突然浮现到意识中。所以这其实是一个有点可怕的想法，你可能会，你的心理景观中可能会潜藏着许多洗脑神曲。只有其中一部分会浮现到意识中，并且被你真正识别出来。但是，是的，确实有些歌曲往往特别洗脑。我的意思是，这不一定对每个人都一样。就像人们，
I've known people who are big classical music heads that can get like a Brahms symphony theme stuck in their head. But typically, it's these really, really catchy songs. You think of like Carly Gray Jepson's Call Me Maybe. People talk about that one a lot. You know, and then there's like really terrible ones, like the, it's a small world after all that plays in the Disney World ride. And there's lots of evidence about what causes something to pop up as an earworm. It helps if it's quite singable kind of song,
我认识一些古典音乐迷，他们的脑海里会挥之不去勃拉姆斯交响乐的主题。但通常情况下，都是这些非常非常洗脑的歌曲。你会想到比如卡莉·蕾·杰普森的《打给我吧》（Call Me Maybe）。人们经常谈论那首。你知道的，还有一些真的很糟糕的歌曲，比如迪士尼乐园游乐设施里播放的《小小世界》（It's a Small World After All）。有很多证据表明是什么导致某首歌作为洗脑神曲突然出现。如果它是一首相当容易哼唱的歌曲，会很有帮助，
straightforward in a tempo that you can kind of like move along with easily. And that it's simple enough that you can kind of follow along, but there's also some hook. There's something a little unusual that you kind of get trip up on or get stuck about. And really, the cues can be quite oblique. So, like, you can be outside on a walk and you pass, like, a dog that seems to be roaming around over here. And then, like, before you know it, you have who let the dogs out stuck in your head. Like, really literal triggers.
节奏直白，你可以轻松地随着它摇摆。而且它足够简单，你可以跟着哼唱，但同时也有一些抓耳的钩子。有些有点不同寻常的东西会让你绊住或者陷进去。真的，线索可以非常间接。所以，比如，你可能在外面散步，然后你路过一只似乎在这里游荡的狗。然后，在你意识到之前，你的脑海里就一直回响着“谁把狗放出来的”（Who Let the Dogs Out）。真的是非常字面意义的触发点。
It's actually something interesting you can do is the next time you have a song stuck in your head, really think back. And it turns out when people try to figure out what prompted it, they're often quite good at it. It's, it had some literal kind of prompt. They're also contagious because this happens at my household all the time that somebody doesn't really realize they have a song stuck in their head. They kind of like hum it without even realizing they're humming it. And then that person humming it like cues it in me. And then I start singing it. And then, you know, my kid is like, what? How did you? Like, that's in my head. Like, what? And so yeah, it really propagates in these kind of zany ways. And they're very normal. This is a really important thing to
实际上，你觉得有趣的是，下一次当你的脑子里挥之不去某首歌时，好好回想一下。结果证明，当人们试图弄清楚是什么触发了它时，他们往往能找得很准。它确实带有某种字面意义上的触发因素。它们也具有传染性，因为这在我的家里经常发生，某人并没有真正意识到他们脑子里挥之不去一首歌。他们会不知不觉地哼唱起来。然后那个人哼唱的歌就像是给我的一个暗示。接着我就开始唱了。然后，你知道的，我的孩子就会说，什么？你怎么会？就像，这在我脑子里。就像，什么？所以，是的，它确实以这种疯狂的方式传播开来。而且它们非常正常。关于洗脑神曲，有一件非常重要的事情需要
know about earworms is like super common. Almost, you know, over 90% of people have them at least once a week. Lots of people have them at least once a day. Very normal. Yeah. And isn't it a goal, say, of Madison Avenue? And they want us to remember their, their annoying jingles. And a lot of us, I know, have commercials stuck in our heads forever. That's exactly right. That's exactly right. And, you know, sometimes there's text that is just so ridiculous that if it was spoken to you, you would just laugh, right? Yet somehow it can like stick it on top of a tune and you're like, you know, singing along. Yeah. That's why there are these hilarious YouTube videos where people just like take songs, song lyrics and
了解，那就是它超级普遍。几乎，你知道的，超过90%的人每周至少经历一次。很多人至少一天经历一次。非常正常。是的，而且麦迪逊大道的目标不正是如此吗？他们希望我们记住他们那些烦人的广告歌。我知道，我们很多人都有永远挥之不去留在脑海里的广告。完全正确。完全正确。而且，你知道的，有时歌词是如此荒谬，如果有人对你大声说出来，你只会笑，对吧？然而，不知何故，它可以把它贴在曲调之上，你就会像，你知道的，跟着唱起来。是的。这就是为什么会有这些搞笑的 YouTube 视频，人们只是把歌曲拿来，把歌词拿出来
read them in a really serious voice. And, you know, it's so silly. Because you can just get away with so much in a song that you can't ordinarily. Now, you're also interested in how music is linked to imagination and how the stories and the images that we associate with types of music can vary by person and by culture. Can you talk about that a bit? Yes. We have this really wild kind of experimental task that we have been using where we've just been playing people clips of songs.
用非常严肃的声音读出来。而且，你知道的，这太蠢了。因为你在歌曲里可以做很多通常做不到的事情。现在，你也对音乐如何与想象力联系在一起感兴趣，以及我们与各类音乐联想到的故事和意象如何因人而异、因文化而异。你能谈谈这个吗？是的。我们有一个非常疯狂的实验任务，我们一直在使用，就是给人们播放歌曲片段。
and we just asked them to tell us a story that they imagined. So we asked them first if they imagined a story. And then if they did, we asked them to tell us their story. And what we're discovering there that is really surprised us so much and has launched a whole series of further studies is that even if I'm just doing this, playing people's songs they've never heard before, one at a time, in a soundproof booth, playing a song, asking them to tell me a story, somebody else seven states away
然后我们只是请他们讲一个他们想象的故事。所以我们首先问他们是否想象了一个故事。然后如果他们想象了，我们请他们讲出他们的故事。我们在那里发现的、让我们大感惊讶并引发了一系列后续研究的内容是，即使我只是这样做，给人们播放他们从未听过的新歌，一次一首，在隔音室里，播放一首歌，让我讲个故事，在七个州之外的另一个人
will do the same thing and they'll tell me the same story so there really are these patterns these sonic patterns that we're picking up just in our environment that have these very clear associational kinds of denotive meanings that people are able to decode and I think this is part of why you can get film music libraries where
也会做同样的事情，他们会讲同样的故事，所以确实存在这些模式，我们在环境中捕捉到的这些声音模式，它们具有这些非常清晰的关联性指示意义，人们能够对其进行解码，我认为这就是为什么你可以找到电影音乐库的原因，
you know, you just can go there and like say, you know, I want music that's for like a chase scene, but it's, you know, really stressful, but it's also kind of funny. And then you have like musical excerpts there for you to use in your film. And the reason that can work is because there just are these found environment patternings that people are incredibly sophisticated and navigators. And so this is a really sensitive way of detectives. that people have grown up with some kind of broadly shared cultural experiences. I can just play you a song, play me a song, and sort of the pictures that we're having in our head are often the same, which I think is most people wouldn't expect and is pretty fun. How do visual images affect our reaction to music? Yeah. I think they're huge. It turns out, you know, even if we just, we've done these studies where we've just asked people after we play them something, what'd you think about while you were listening to that? They could say it. They could be like, oh, I was thinking it was too loud or like, oh, I was thinking I needed a sandwich or,
你知道的，你只要去那里说，你知道的，我想要一段像是追逐场景的音乐，但它，你知道的，压力很大，但同时也挺搞笑的。然后你就有音乐片段供你在电影中使用。之所以行得通，是因为确实存在这些人们极其擅长导航的环境模式。所以这是一种非常敏感的侦测方式。人们在成长过程中拥有某种广泛共享的文化经历。我可以放一首歌给你听，放一首歌给我听，我们在脑海中浮现的画面往往是相同的，我认为这是大多数人意料之外的，而且相当有趣。视觉图像如何影响我们对音乐的反应？是的。我认为它们非常巨大。事实证明，你知道的，即使我们只是，我们做过这些研究，在我们给人们播放某些东西后，只是问他们，你在听的时候想到了什么？他们能说出来。他们可能会说，哦，我觉得声音太大了，或者，哦，我觉得我需要一个三明治，或者，
you know, they could say anything. And the most common things they end up saying are like picturing some kind of fictional story, picturing like a movie, remembering something that really happened to them, visual imagery. So all these things that are these like imaginative kind of remembered responses. And I think this is one of the ways we zone out frequently in a very pleasant way when we're listening to music. It sort of enables us to coast on it or daydream in this way that can be very satisfying. And in fact, where a lot of our emotional response to music might come from, right? It might not be like exactly that the sound itself is cueing an emotion. it could be rather that the sound is queuing some specific image or it's cueing some memory and that image or memory is cueing the emotion.
你知道的，他们什么都可以说。他们最后说的最常见的事情是描绘某种虚构的故事、描绘像电影一样的画面、想起真正发生在他们身上的事情、视觉意象。所以所有这些都是这种富有想象力的、被记住的反应。我认为这是我们在听音乐时经常以非常愉快的方式放空自己的方式之一。它某种程度上使我们能够顺其自然，或者以这种可以非常满足的方式白日做梦。事实上，我们对音乐的很多情感反应可能正是来源于此，对吧？可能并不完全是声音本身在触发某种情绪，而可能是声音在触发某些特定的图像或触发某种记忆，而该图像或记忆正在触发情绪。
And I think that's really something that's happening a lot more than we might expect. Given these almost universal connections between music and certain emotions, how effective is music as a therapeutic device? There's so much interesting work in that space right now. And I think one of the really kind of like interesting problems that people are trying to crack there is figuring out how instead of like having a one size fits all like here, you know, use this Leonard Skinnerd song and this will cure all of your your in homes. But it's like, you know, what do we know about your cultural backgrounds? like what kind of stuff have you listened to? How can we kind of tailor like a musical program for you for whatever the circumstance may be? And I think it's in that space that a lot of really interesting work on music and medicine is happening at the moment. And what's next for you?
我认为这确实比我们预期的要发生得频繁得多。鉴于音乐与某些情绪之间几乎普遍存在的联系，音乐作为一种治疗手段有多大效果？目前在该领域有大量有趣的工作。我认为人们试图在那里攻克的真正有趣的问题之一是，弄清楚如何不再采用千篇一律的做法，比如“给，你知道的，用这首林纳德·斯金纳德的歌，这将治愈你所有的毛病”。而是，你知道的，我们对你的文化背景了解多少？你听过什么样的东西？我们如何针对你的情况（无论身处何种环境）为你量身定制音乐节目？我认为正是在这个领域，目前正在开展大量关于音乐与医学的非常有趣的工作。对你来说接下来是什么？
What are the big questions you're looking at now? I'm so interested in this whole phenomenon of musical daydreams, mostly because the same way that earworms, it felt like people harbored them secretly and for a while. And like if someone out there like, what? You have earworms too? Until kind of it started coming out in, you know, people were like, wait, earworms are a thing. And then there was like research about them. And it was like, that's very cathartic. I feel like daydreams occupy a little bit of the same space where like sometimes you're listening to music and you might feel you're doing it wrong because you're like not paying attention. But we're seeing that actually the daydreams people,
你现在关注的重大问题是什么？我对音乐白日梦的整个现象非常感兴趣，主要是因为和洗脑神曲一样，感觉人们曾将它们秘密地藏在心里一段时间。就像如果外面有人说，什么？你脑子里也有洗脑神曲？直到它开始在人群中传开，你知道的，人们开始说，等等，洗脑神曲是真实存在的。然后就有了关于它们的研究。感觉这非常具有宣泄作用。我觉得白日梦也占据了类似的空间，有时你在听音乐，你可能会觉得自己做错了，因为你好像没有在注意听。但我们看到，实际上人们的白日梦
experience track very closely the particular changes and events that are happening in the music. So you are listening. You're listening in this way where it's fueling some really kind of important set of images or imagined experiences or remembered experiences that you're having. So we're really working on studying those from a whole bunch of different perspectives. Well, Dr. Margulis, I want to thank you for joining me. We could go on forever talking about music. There's just so many interesting aspects of what you're working on. Thank you. Thank you so much.
体验与音乐中发生的特定变化和事件高度契合。所以你在听。你以这种方式在听，它激发了你脑海中某些非常重要的图像集合、想象体验或记忆体验。所以我们确实在从各种不同的角度致力于研究它们。好吧，玛古利斯博士，我想感谢你加入我。我们可以永远谈论音乐。你正在从事的工作有太多有趣的方面了。谢谢。非常感谢。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学闲谈》节目。如果你喜欢我们听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 与我们联系。《心理学闲谈》由莉·温德曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。